Donald Trump's lawyers want one of his
criminal trials postponed indefinitely
why not right I mean shoot your shot you
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
you don't take obviously this is Bonkers
and as usual they are they're they're
justifying this request by saying we
can't have this interfering with his run
for president it's a form of election
interference it's potentially uh
prejudicial to have this criminal trial
related to the documents going on while
Trump is President what's funny is this
is while Trump is running for president
when Trump was President they said no no
no no there can't be any investigations
there can't be any charges because Trump
is President then it was well this is a
former president then we can't do that
either because of convention or because
of law now it's he's a can that it once
again so we also can't do it and we all
know that if by some horrible situation
Trump ends up president again then they
will say well you can't have the sitting
president on trial so we have to
postpone it again